c'est déjà ce qu'on fait aujourd'hui
enfin c'est ce qu'on fait depuis depuis
quarante voire voir que le voir saint
quentin d essayer de cibler et de donner
à ceux qui en ont besoin et de donner
aux pauvres du coup on voit qu'on a
plein de problèmes pour ça notamment
déjà européen repérer les personnes qui
en ont vraiment besoin
il ya aussi plein de deux remparts tels
que tel que les remparts administratif
il ya des gens qui ne demandent pas les
aides donc je suis d'accord une première
étape ce serait une automatisation des
aides actuelles mais sur l'argument de
dire il n'y en a qui en ont pas besoin
mais en plaques de revenu universel il
faut pas oublier qu'il doit être financé
ça c'est sûr et il est financé par la
contribution nationale
voilà on va chercher l'argent là où il y
en a donc de toutes façons si vous en
êtes si vous gagnez assez pour pour
subvenir à vos besoins et enfin plus
vous allez de toute façon rembourser
leurs billets de base quoi qu'il arrive
demain monsieur françois pinault va
payer plusieurs fois ce qui va recevoir
un revenu de base le système il est
simple est-ce que c'est ce qui a été
rappelé par daniel zamora et c'est ça
qui fait qu' il est efficace
on donne sans contrepartie sans demander
de dossiers sont demandés de
vérification n'a en termes de revenus
cela ce sera après coup fait par
l'imposition par le système fiscal
[Musique]